washington et puis fm américain qui
risque de revenir pendant la prochaine
campagne électorale le pays fonctionne
maintenant avec une sécurité sociale à
deux vitesses hillary clinton avait bien
tenté de mettre sur place un plan de
réforme mais aujourd'hui ce sont les
assurances privées qui prennent en
charge les malades
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux aux
états unis xavier à gland et myriam
métaoui les troubles de la vue du myriam
gutman sont apparus il ya quatre ans
alors qu'elle emmenait des enfants en
voiture à la crèche
d'abord elle a commencé à ne plus
percevoir les couleurs puis jour après
jour sa vision s'est fait de moins en
moins précises
à quoi ça ressemblait et c'était comme
ça comme du brouillard et j'en étais
fois où je ne savais plus il y avait du
brouillard dehors ou citer mes yeux mais
madame gutmann va voir alors le médecin
de l'assurance à laquelle elles cotisent
depuis 44 ans rapidement celui-ci
diagnostic une cataracte
mais reculent de semaine en semaine la
décision de la faire opérer
officiellement il trouve l'opération
trop risquée en fait elle comprend qu
ils renâclent engagé les frais seulement
la vue de madame gutmann se dégrade de
plus en plus elle fini par contacter un
autre médecin qui lui organise enfin
l'intervention
je ne fais plus confiance à mon docteur
et c'est une chose terrible
ce n'est pas bon vous devriez avoir
entièrement confiance en votre docteur
particulièrement lorsque vous
vieillissez tant que les assurances et
contrôleront le système des gens
pourront mourir ou avoir des problèmes
aux moines parce que l'argent passe
avant la santé aux états unis seuls les
plus pauvres et les retraités
bénéficient d'une sorte de sécurité
sociale pour les autres rien sinon des
assurances privées 140 millions
d'américains dépendant de ce système
soit un marché de 1200 milliards de
dollars par an une somme colossale pour
limiter les coûts de gestion et dégager
des bénéfices
les assurances ont mis en place un
encadrement rigoureux des dépenses de
santé
elles passent des contrats avec les
hôpitaux et les médecins une garantie de
revenus en échange d'un contrôle du
moindre de leurs actes oh ce qui dépasse
les prescriptions et bien même des
sanctions
les compagnies d'assurances voir décide
souvent quels médicaments doivent être
prescrits
s'il y avait mes diamants pour la même
maladie en est s'il voit que la d'entre
eux coûtent moins cher ils vont la
poisse et de préférence à tout aux trucs
avec une centaine d'autres médecin
new-yorkais
le docteur guillory s'est révolté contre
cette logique financière elle le prive
de sa liberté de prescrire et de soigner
comme il le décide
et comme ceux qui viennent le consulter
prennent le risque de ne pas être
remboursés par leur assurance
il ne fait pas payer les plus pauvres
d'entre eux une certaine vision de la
médecine
c'est important d'avoir un contact dans
la durée avec le patient uniquement sur
le plan médical en route quand il s'en
va il sait qu'il a eu une bonne
consultation et que son médecin sera
toujours là pour l'écouter
mais je crois que c'est ce qu'il ya de
mieux après des mois de bataille
myriam gutman a obtenu le remboursement
de son opération aujourd'hui allez voir
beaucoup plus clair dans le système de
santé américain